bonjour à tous et monsieur greu février
2018 je découvrais le week au vieux de
pro ou awc à barcelone le 26 mai
2010huit publié une vidéo d'eux boxing
du bic au lieu de pro est aujourd'hui mi
juin 2010 vous faire un test complet du
ricoh view de pro que j'ai ici et on y
va
[Musique]
nikos et la marque française qui monte
qui monte qui monte qui monte ils font
des produits de plus en plus intéressant
c'est vrai qu'au début on mikko était
connu pour avoir des produits
d'entretien pour un public très jeune
donc forcément pas cher des produits qui
étaient assez comment dire d'entrée de
gamme un bon c'était pas mal pas non
plus extraordinaire
et oui qu est en train vraiment de monte
monte monte en gamme pour proposer des
produits déjà qui est éthiquement sont
plus dans ce qu'on retrouve actuellement
sur les produits milieu de gamme et haut
de gamme
un design revu corrigé des
caractéristiques techniques qui sont
plus intéressantes et des produits qui
pourront signer forcément pour plus de
monde un public jeune mais pas que un
public aussi oula je vais faire tomber
aussi un public un petit peu plus old
school comme moi voilà donc aujourd'hui
on va tester ce week au vu de pro voir
s'il est intéressant je vous invite à
lire voir la vidéo donne boxing pour le
découvrir un petit peu tranquillement
tranquillement une fois qu'on l'a ouvert
qu'on l'a découvert qu on sait qu hier
semble qu'on a fait le tour complet on
va rentrer plus en détail dans ce
produit dans cette vidéo à faire
différents tests on a ramené un point de
vue performances ci fonctionne on va
regarder l'eau est ce qu'on va voir
s'ils répondent bien on va tester la
vidéo la photo avec le double capteur
arrière et le capteur avant on va tester
aussi l'audio voir si l'audio fonctionne
bien faire un tour un peu complet de la
machine pour au final pouvoir vous dire
est ce qu'il est intéressant d'acheter
ce week au lieu de proue ou alors est-ce
qu'il faut passer son tour
c'est mieux de prendre vous intéresse
vous ai fait une sélection de prix je
vous ai mis en bas dans la description
comme ça vous allez pouvoir voir quel
est le meilleur endroit pour l'acheter
pour vous faire plaisir sur un petit
tour du côté du design moi je trouve pas
mal franchement on va pas se mentir je
trouve que pour le coup vicaut a
vraiment bien réussi son modèle vous
avez à l'arrière un dos qui laisse
malgré tout des traces de doigts on n'a
pas trop lui en vouloir parce qu'à
énormément de produits avec des dons
envers qui laisse des traces de doigts
là ici pas le dos en verre mais radio
sont quand même au rendez vous malgré
tout je trouve que ce qui est vraiment
très très bien réussi c'est le fait
d'avoir positionne f4 d'empreintes
digitales ici et le module photo ici le
choix est assez intéressant malgré tout
parce que vous trouverez facilement
votre position pour déverrouiller ici
c'est assez logique mais on va pas
laisser ses traces de doigts là dessus
voilà le dos et bien fait vous avez ici
la marque rico
design je trouve qu'il est il est assez
bien réussi assez élégant pour trouver
un port micro usb pour la recharge
forcément c'est une question de coût
j'imagine que l'usb this elle a coûté
plus cher haut parleur mono on testera
tout à l'heure le port jack qui est ici
c'est pareil on testera conversys
intéressant au trafic soit aussi réussie
c'est l'écran vous avez un écran 6
pouces une résolution 1528 par 720
pixels c'est effectivement pas du full
hd mais malgré tout ça fonctionne plutôt
pas mal l'affichage est correct les
couleurs sont bien le rendu est bien les
contrastes ont pas mal
on n'est pas sur un écran de dingue on
est sur du lcd mais je trouve qu'il a
bien la faire le rendu n'est sans doute
pas c'est assez agréable pour avoir
utilisé pendant plusieurs jours dans ce
que vous n'aviez que vous regardez les
vidéos vous souffrez pas d'un écran
mauvaise qualité dont bon là dessus
aussi je donnerai un point assez positif
à wilkow pour appeler quand même qu'on
est sur un produit qui coûte 300 euros
on va pas aller chercher les
performances nous fout on va pas lui
demander la lune donc il faut mesurer
ses propos on n'est pas sur un produit
qui coûte 800 900 mille euros sur lequel
on va avoir des exigences de fous
furieux
je trouve que là pour le prix n'ont
vraiment pas se plaindre
le produit pour l'instant c'est vraiment
bien john l'écran une fois de plus
lorsque vous regardez des vidéos
fonctionne bien vous pouvez agrandir
alors effectivement on a cette petite
encoche mais le fait une toute petite
encoche sur la gauche
ah on dit ça gêne pas pour moi ça me
pose absolument aucun problème plutôt
qu'avoir un grand bloc sur le côté vous
avez malgré tout une encoche casse et
discrète
après cet effet de zoom il a son côté
négatif c'est que sa bourgogne une
partie de l'image sur le haut et sur le
bas donc ça dépend vraiment de ce qu'a
voulu montrer le créateur ça dépend de
la vidéo qu'on regarde pas ce que ça
peut rapidement nous enlever des
éléments l'image mais ça vous l'aurez
sur tous les écrans avec ce type de
format et malgré tout schuss que le
coach est assez discrète dont bon là ça
fonctionne en termes de performance je
trouve pas mal
il réagit plutôt bien bon alors vous
avez pas non plus un processeur d'1ghz
instinct dragonne 450 octas core cadencé
à 1,8 ghz si vous avez 4 gigas de ram
donc on va pas non plus aller chercher
des performances de fou mais il répond
bien vous pouvez naviguer facilement
vous pouvez jouer lors des petits jeux
vous n'allez pas chercher un truc avec
des performances de dingue mais bon sur
le principe fonctionne bien la fluidité
et là vous pouvez jouer à quelques jeux
pas des trucs de fou du point de vue la
batterie je trouve pas particulièrement
gourmand vous avez une batterie de 3000
millions perreur voulait le garder
plusieurs jours en mode veille et vous
pouvez l'utiliser une journée sans hong
kong sans problème en utilisation
classique si vous pousser dans ses
retranchements si vous jouez énormément
si vous sollicite énormément
c'est un peu comme tous les smartphones
il va se décharger assez rapidement idem
en termes de stockage vous serez pas
déborder 64 giga j'ai déjà utilisé 14
igas sur les 64 g
man gestionnaires d espaces de stockage
peut voir ce que j'ai utilisée entre mes
photos mes vidéos ma musique mais je
m'estime et ça c'est plutôt bien de ce
point de vue là je pense pas non plus
que vous allez manquer d'autant plus
qu'il est extensible avec une carte
micro sd point très positif le
déverrouillage à ce que ce soit avec le
capteur d'empreintes digitales ou avec
le façonne locke fonctionne très bien
c'est extrêmement rapide illustration je
regarde il dès lors où tout de suite ça
va très vite pareil pour capteur
d'empreintes digitales je pose mon doigt
sa déverrouille donc ça ça fonctionne
aussi extrêmement bien et maintenant du
point de vue de l'audio il crache et
crash mais plutôt fort quand on regarde
comme ça on pourrait croire qu à des
haut parleurs stéréo
en fait c'est du haut parleur mono
gardez vous écoute et hop j'en doute un
jeu bouche c'est le bouche la bêta de
son jeu bouche l'autre il ya du sens
donc les haut parleurs
c'est celui là par construction crh
vraiment fort et ça c'est vraiment bien
le son est bien c'est donc un haut
parleur mono et non pas des haut
parleurs stéréo mais une fois de plus un
smartphone à 300 euros va pas lui
demander la lune la prise jack et pas
mal et pas mal mais le son est pas super
super super fort là je les pousse à fond
j'ai mis un manceau de radiohead nos
surprises
j'adore ce morceau je suis vraiment
maximum du volume alors forcément je
donne un peu parce que radiohead d'un
des oreilles forcément mais on pourra
voir remonter plus fort elle lâche peut
pas chien max c'est un peu le côté
frustrant néanmoins vous avez un bon
volume sonore alors ce que je vais
recommander là dessus c'est utiliser des
casques actifs qui vont vraiment vous
coupé de l'extérieur
si vous voulez en profiter je n'ai pas
entendu un nom bruyant on manque un
petit peu de puissance au niveau du
casque une fois de plus on peut pas tout
avoir
néanmoins et ça c'est un point positif
évitez que vous flinguer les oreilles
faire attention à vous quand même
je vais également quentin d'ici quelques
jours un comparatif entre le samsung
galaxy à 6 et loïc aux yeux de pro qui
sont tous les deux sensiblement au même
tarif pour vous aider à savoir lequel
choisir entre le à six ailes view de pro
et maintenant qu'en est il du côté photo
vidéo
c'est peut-être là que le bât blesse
suède explique ça c'est moi du côté de
la photo et dès que je passais en vidéo
on a une petite compensation du point de
vue de la stabilisation donc ça c'est la
caméra de celle fille maintenant à
tester la caméra principale au dos de
l'appareil
las en mode photo donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez classique d'ex passe en
mode vidéo tout de suite
hop aph et si je veux profiter d'un
grand temps que je passe un deuxième
module photo et là paf ça déforme
alors forcément qui dit grand-angle dit
quelque chose qui est quand même
légèrement arrondi sur les côtés voilà
ça je suis pas très très très très grand
fan je trouve que le rendu
et pas extraordinaire bon une fois de
plus c'est un smartphone à 300 euros
mais alors que penser de ce vieux de pro
est ce qu'il est bien est ce qu'il est
intéressant est ce que la photo est ce
que la vidéo sont au rendez vous ce que
je vous propose c'est que je suis dans
mon studio c'est de tester directement
on va les voir en extérieur si le rendu
est intéressant on ya tout de suite
du point de vue vidéo le rendu est pas
mal pas extraordinaire c'est pas la
grande qualité mais ça fonctionne par
contre dès qu'on passe en grand-angle si
tout de suite un peu moins bien
alors effectivement le rendu est
beaucoup plus large mais je trouve que
d'emplois de qualité s'est pas encore
tout à fait ça après une fois de plus il
coûte 300 euros
oui qu augmente en gamme et ça c'est
peut-être pas positif la notation sur la
stabilisation c'est pas hyper hyper
convaincu avec sa stabilisation logiciel
c'est pas mal moi tu te sens un petit
peu avant la tremblote là pour le coup
ça stabilise un peu il ya pire ya lieu
mal m'en foutiste orlanda ça devrait
quand même plutôt pas trop mal se passer
du point de vue c'est chiche ça
fonctionne ça fait son petit effet c'est
pas non plus un truc de dingue c'est pas
non plus la meilleure caméra celle ci
qu'on puisse trouver sur le marché
mais bon dans l'absolu ça fonctionne
quand même la jeune femme sans les
caméras avant dans le noir donc
effectivement vous avez un grain sur
l'écran et aucun éclairage est juste un
petit peu de lumière extérieure mais
deux volets fermés donc on va pas grand
chose je vais même telles sont les
caméras hier c'est vrai que c'est pas un
smartphone qui était pour fonctionner en
faible luminosité
et ça on le voit tout de suite
d'ailleurs vous avez la lumière
extérieure ça fonctionne mais là
vraiment n'ai pas beaucoup lumière donc
on va pas non plus lui reprocher dès que
vous n'avez pas de lumière ils souffrent
énormément
une fois de plus c'est un smartphone à
300 euros on peut pas trop lui en
vouloir
là j'ai pris une photo avec l'objectif
arrière il a un petit peu de mal à faire
le point sur cette fleur devant et c'est
ce côté là qui effectivement est dommage
après lorsque je passe sans grand-angle
tout de suite ça vous davantage
je suis quand même beaucoup moins fun
mais bon ça le mérite d'exister personne
fait une belle tête de vainqueur sur des
photos celles fille mais ça fonctionne
également la sq est sympa c'est qu'il va
reconnaître le sourire et dès qu'un
sourire paf il fait une photo je suis
pas sûre ce sera mon plus beau sourire
mais bon à réméré de fonctionner il
existe plusieurs modes vous avez ici le
panorama la vidéo classique avec le
grand angle la photo classique avec le
grand-angle voyage dans le temps tout de
suite ça va déformer un petit peu
l'image savall arrondir forcément vous
avez aussi le faith beauty un mode
professionnel un super pixels un
monument
et un time lapse du le slow motion du
tactile lorsque vous voulez prendre une
photo vous avez le filigrane pour
ajouter la pub le liant tes sentiments
50 hertz la qualité l'image que vous
pouvez régler ici activer/désactiver
leçon pellicule retardateur ya pas mal
de petites possibilités et je dois
reconnaître que dans l'ensemble c'est
quand même assez bien penser pareil
pouvant photo pouvez activer désactiver
le flash choisir le mode 4/3 met du hdr
et vous avez aussi des filtres de
couleurs côté photo vidéo il fonctionne
pas mal c'est pas extraordinaire situe
dans l'antre 2 c'est pas mauvais on va
pas se mentir c'est pas du tout mauvais
c'est pas non plus top je tiens à
préciser que sauf que oui quoi faire
vrai bel effort vraiment fait un produit
qui est vraiment bien dessinée qui est
très jolie qui a un bel écran de 6
pouces
la résolution est pas mal le produit
fini et bien il fonctionne bien et
déverrouille rapidement il est fluide
c'est pas non plus une bête de compet
une fois de plus c'est un smartphone à
300 euros
vous êtes sur un point vidéo lycos et
plus haut de gamme de wilko que je
trouve que ce vieux de pros de
l'ensemble est quand même un très bon
produit il ya un petit bémol du côté de
la photo et de la vidéo sont forcément
des points qui vont être corrigée et
améliorée par miku au fur et à mesure du
temps sur les modèles qui vont arriver
d'ailleurs je vous invite à vous abonner
parce que mal cette femme se retourner
les voir à l'ifa sur leur stand et là il
devrait y avoir aussi d'autres
nouveautés
donc si vous êtes intéressés abonnez
vous mais dans l'ensemble le vieux de
pro est quand même un très bon produit
oui causé une marque connue pour des
produits d'entrée de gamme et je trouve
qu'avec le vieux de pros ils font leur
entrée dans le milieu de gamme c'est le
produit le plus haut de gamme de wilco
et ça leur permet de franchir un pas
supplémentaire et de se montrer comme
l'entreprise qui est capable de se
réinventer et de proposer des produits
qui sont quand même beaucoup plus sympa
que ce qu'on pouvait retrouver
auparavant chez eux
bilan final est ce que ce week au view
de provoc ou est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter
oui ou non si vous avez un budget aux
autres des 300 euros est-ce que vous
pouvez aller dessus je dirais oui oui
dès lors que le design vous plaît dès
lors que l' écran 6 pouces vous convient
dès lors que vous avez envie de faire
des jeux pas trop gourmands vous voulez
regarder de la vidéo voulait faire des
mails naviguer sur internet utiliser des
réseaux sociaux
oui si vous voulez faire des photos
vidéos souvenirs si vous voulez partager
sur les réseaux sociaux mais sans
prétention sans vouloir faire de la
vidéo de qualité sans vouloir faire la
photo de qualité
vous pouvez aller sur le but
prot si par contre vous les privilégiés
la photo la vidéo y avoir des rendus de
très bonne qualité parce que vous filmez
énormément parce que vous faites
beaucoup de photos et que c'est votre
passion vous passez votre tour
c'est pas du tout l'adn de ce produit ce
produit est assez bon de tous les points
de vue il n'excelle pas il n'est pas
extraordinaire sur la photo de la vidéo
mais par contre il a un rendu qui est
vraiment correct dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà
eu des produits de huy qu est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter par ce
week au vu de pro est ce que vous avez
envie de l'acheter si vous intéresse je
vous amis tous les liens dans la
description marc dumas vos commentaires
avis suggestions et je vous dis je vais
retourner voir oui qu au mois de
septembre à l'ifa à berlin
donc on reste connectés merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'ai été
amenée c'est comme d'hab de jolis pouces
soyez sages prenez soin de vous et à
bientôt
ciao
[Musique]